Science provides new hope for paraplegics!
You go, science.
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews with some exciting
news - as of this week, we are one step closer
to a cure for paralysis!
An experimental new treatment called "epidural
stimulation" has given new hope to men and
women suffering from chronic paralysis.
Three years ago, doctors at the National Institute
of Health successfully rehabilitated a man
who was paralyzed from the neck down, by zapping
his spinal cord with electricity.
Ever since that miraculous recovery, doctors
have wondered if it was just a fluke - or
a potential avenue for future therapy.
Fast forward 3 years, to this week - when
the team of doctors that initially made that
discovery, managed to replicate it 3 more
times, with 3 different male patients - all
of whom suffered spinal cord injuries that
left them paralyzed from below the neck or
chest for at least two years.
Treatment involves implanting a suite of electrodes
in the vertebrae of the spinal cord, and administering
doses of electricity.
Those electrical impulses allow the spinal
cord to receive simple commands from the brain,
through circuitry that was previously considered
irreparable after spinal cord injury.
All 4 patients are now capable of some degree
of voluntary motion, but they still aren't
able to walk unassisted.
The simple act of lifting their legs and standing,
however, is still a huge improvement over
complete paralysation.
One patient noted that even when the machine
was turned off, he saw "huge improvements
in bowel, bladder and sexual function."
Obviously this treatment is still experimental
- but experts say it could eventually prove
more effective than standard approaches, including
medicine and physical therapy.
"The big message," they say, is that people
with spinal cord injuries of this type "no
longer need to think they have a lifelong
sentence of paralysis."
What about you?
Does this give you hope for the future of
paralysis patients?
Let us know in the comments down below, and
for more happy stories like this one - be
sure to check out testtube.com/dnews.